I love to play with human bodies
because everyone can connect with it.
Everyone is a human, basically.
People come to me saying
that they like the way
I'm thinking because the clip is
a little bit different,
so not too obvious.
You really have to think when you see it.
You really have to think,
"What does it mean?"
I'm trying to hide the
obvious, so not like...
because when you go today on
the social media channels,
you scroll down and everything is like
seen a thousand times.
It's somehow disgusting,
but with the colors
and everything it's nothing.
That's why I'm using also
these really light monotone
colors because frankly,
if I would use dark stuff,
everyone would say this is
disgusting, this is s---,
and I don't wanna watch it.
It was basically to learn the 3D program,
which I'm working on
mostly, and this 3D program
is really good for simulations and VFX,
and I had a really big motivation, like,
I was also coming home
after my working hours,
grabbing my iPad, and I was watching
three or four hours of tutorials
just to learn something.
When I started, every
clip was like a challenge
in terms of technical set-up,
and I realized really fast
that it's more than just a technical test.
And now it's basically like an
art and a business at the same time.
When I'm posting something there are tons
of comments and reshares automatically.
It's crazy. I can just wait.
If I post something, I can
wait, the next two days
I'm getting job requests
also from big companies.
It's really important in 3D
that you know what you're doing
before you start because, as I said,
simulations are really time-consuming,
so for a five-second
clip you sometimes need
three or four days to get it perfectly
because simulations are
really hard to art direct,
and it's more a little bit luck
and experience at the same time.
For me it's like a game, a puzzle,
this program, it's fun
and work at the same time.